вуаля
краще круасан париже а значить у
всім у свиті
його випікайте славою та пекарні бенджамін
на тертці серце кінця російської столиці
скомандую зовні за знанням розуму
випікаємо і моєї ж 900 кроса не враховано
небезпечного та круасани такі популярні
ще й фарбу отримає образу allow чим же
секрет ідеального круасану
ось градієнта гараж not support асель 3
і сухого молока бог ще з опитуванням
чи то бенджамін до дає року 3g в те
води алекс оцінку ростів вид їжі
паторни
авто вал і рів а ми викури сови ось уже
холодну воду з його холодну кісту ідріс
де починають приймати та терміни реферат
за кілька хвилин машина змішуємо
градієнта в одній масу хочемо тісто
ділять на шладке у формі цих коль і
дають йому перекочує і взводом пекарі
надають тесту прямо путній форм та його
позбавляють
мобільнику на 2 1 і тепер місце на годину
до дати горшкова та олії найвищу я
кістки далі кісту розгойдує щоб вона
була лиша сантиметр зав.
бенджамін повністю засмагу то і масло в
тісто та його ще раз розгойдує стоп стоп
оборот так і процес називають ламін
увальнем самоцінна та я круассанам
характерна за вітриною структури я
завершив утомлену стадію зарости 100 майна
біляш за вітром на структуру вона
складаєте приблизно стоїте 36 і шариф
чистота олії джамін лікар але вирізає
рекут на чекісті 100т порвані знову
майка фулону ти на димному щоб у того
дня куроса ним забору ще найменший
цілий день якір і скручує треку
Тачки в потрібну форму якщо він травня не
красти у форму ночам оленька ейфелева
бачу
паста не про готовальню перед випіканням
benjamins відбувається і зграя вічним
спреєм спеціально за для хрускіт до позову
ринку 200 градусів та 20 грн
територію тісто на маленький шедевр
бенджамін дуже їжте готовим продуктом
гавайську але він ідеальний кроса тут
видно шкіряний україни shark божевільний
гвинт повз сну
буму склалося з риданням хтось панове
битися і кейвінгом нам допоможе вуаля
iPhone і найкраще круасани в Парижі